okay hi i'm jason underwood
and i'm a principal scientist for pac
bio where i focus
mainly on rna work and
these days most people are talking about
a 30 kilobase long rna
called sars 2. but today i'm going to
tell you
about our efforts to sequence full
length
transcripts but with single cell
information
encoded into the sequencing reads
and so our real motivation for this is
watching what's been going on in the
biological community
and the applications of single cell
techniques to
many different aspects of biology and
even medicine
and so the theme that we're seeing that
goes through
many of these studies is that no matter
what technology here
uh the whatever single cellulizer you're
using
the main theme is to increase the number
of reads and
increase the number of cells that are
assayed at one time
and so this is a a clustering that shows
2 million mouse cells
that have been evaluated at one time
but the theme that does seem to run
through these studies as well
is that there's a measurement of gene
expression
and one thing we know is that it's not
just
genes that are being expressed in
mammalian cells but
isoforms so most genes make multiple
isoforms
and so in that case we want to be able
to study that information
with that kind of full-length context
and so this is an example showing three
different isoforms made from one gene
these might have different cellular
localization or a dominant
negative effect they could have
completely different functions in the
cell
but when they're measured by common
methods in this case
three prime tagging such as the 10x or
sky rnac
methods just a short tag is tagged at
that
three prime end of the transcript
and this is similar for what i call
transcriptional unit tagging
where a transcript is evaluated by short
reads that
span along different spots on the
transcript and even sometimes in
introns and then occasionally you catch
reads that do span an exon exon junction
but you don't necessarily have the
information to stitch together
a full-length rna that can be acid
or or actually assigned to what protein
it would generate in the cell and thus
what function it would serve
so we decided to approach this problem
using
pac bio's approach to rna sequencing
which we call isoseq or isoform
sequencing
so isoc takes advantage of the full
length rna
information by generating a full-length
cdna that goes into
our sequencing technology which can
generate long accurate reads
and so there's no assembly required
during
the evaluation rather you just
get a full-length full-length sequence
so the engine behind isoseq is sort of
performing a reverse transcription from
rna so poly arna is reverse transcribed
from
its uh it's three prime end and a
template switch oligo
is used to generate a sequence of a
known sequence at the five prime end
and now this is capable of going into
pcr and we can generate
what we call a smart bell library so
this is a covalently closed
piece of dna that can go into our
sequencing instrument
and so the way our sequencing works is
we generate very long polymerase reads
where the polymerase goes around and
around
this smart bell and generates reads on
both strands
and then once these are aligned to each
other we can generate
what we call a hi-fi read so our runs
with isis can generate around four to
five million
full-length reads and these are over 99
accurate so these are very nicely uh
capable of
of doing many things in the bulk level
and we've we've seen many examples
of using that for studying uh biology
and and for doing annotation of genomes
but with these this kind of accuracy we
thought we might be able to now apply
this to
single cell as well so a normal isisque
library as depicted in the upper left
has a five prime primer a trans the
transcript sequence a poly a tail and a
three prime primer
on the right you see a single cell cdna
and so this is many
many platforms that use this actually
take advantage of a very similar
mechanism to generate cdna
with the template switch oligo and pcr
however many platforms encode additional
information
at the ends of the transcript like a
unique molecular index
umi or a cellular barcode and so we
thought well can we take the same
information
from these reads from a single cell
platform and
go ahead and call what we would call
this this umi
and barcode information and so this plot
shows you
that on the x-axis is where we rank
all the bar codes in a single cell
sequencing run that came from uh
the 10x platform with the human cell
line k562
in conjunction with uh mount sinai
and then on the y-axis is showing the
illumina barcode rankings and so we
identified 2 55 cells
that were sort of thought of as the
cells of interest so had enough reads in
the 10x data on illumina
and we found all of these exact same
barcodes in the pack bio data as well
and this is by directly reading the the
you know the fasta information out of
the sequencing it's not by
looking at the barcodes off of each
other so i thought this is something
that we could go ahead and
and use uh to go ahead and
use uh pac bio to study single cell
libraries that were already being
generated by people
that were doing uh these kinds of things
on a short read platform and getting
three prime information for example
so i'm going to talk about a couple
different platforms that we've used for
this kind of analysis
and one that i i'm not going to talk
about that
that i've used personally but has been
used a couple times in the field
is using the 10x chromium three prime
solution
combining this with long reads so one of
these papers is from
gupta at all from hagen-tildner's lab
at cornell where they used the chromium
instrument to study mouse brain
development
and then the other is from a group at
the earlham institute led by ian
mccauley
and laura mincarelli's paper showed
uh analysis with both isoseq and short
reads
studying mouse hematopoiesis
and so just a couple of snippets from
that data that was quite exciting i
think
from the hog and tiltingers lab is
this shows this graphic from the paper
from the gene
bin one and so you can see that these
individual tracks
are showing the reeds that are generated
from
individual cell types so these are
neurons in the top rows and then
astrocytes glia
and oligodendrocyte precursors on the
lower half
and if you look at those orange exons on
the right
you can see that they're often included
in the
neural transcripts but when you go down
into the astrocytes glia
and oligodendrocyte precursors you see
that these are not
included as often and if you look at the
gen code annotations below they're sort
of
these are known to be alternative
splicing events
but now with this technique they could
take advantage
of this information to track which
isoform
is in which cell and the brain is an
extremely exciting place to do this
because there's such
diverse alternative splicing and cool
biology behind that
and then second i think this this paper
that just came out last week
from the earlham institute has
the combined single cell from short and
long reads
and they were studying young mice and
aging mice
and looking at what their stem and
progenitor cells were doing
in the bone marrow so what's happening
in hematopoiesis
in these and a really interesting result
that
i thought uh what came out of this is
that they saw that in the igkc
locus so this is an immunoglobulin gene
that they could see that in aging mice
the amount of
igkc expression in short reads was
was quite increased so that's the red
here versus the
the blue but when they went over and
looked at the same data
with the long reads they could actually
see something
far more more interesting i think so at
the top of this
this graph you see the the constant
regions
are at the right side of the igkc
gene and of course these undergo vdj
recombination
uh in in the organism so this is a
rearrangement of the dna
so you could see in the young mice there
was a very
pretty simple set of the uh
these sort of germline igkc
transcripts but when they look in the
the aging mice they saw a far larger
diversity so
it wasn't just that they were studying
that the gene went
up they actually were studying that the
gene actually diversified quite
significantly
and remember that with the three prime
end only information they would not have
uncovered this kind of phenomena so
we've we've also uh taken on
a few different platforms at pac bio
through collaboration
and so i'm going to speak to you about a
couple of those and
cover some of that data so one of those
is
the drop seat technique so this is
another microfluidic
technique similar to 10x but instead of
doing reverse transcription and emulsion
the emulsion is broken and reverse
transcription is done
just in a test tube and so
we tried this using dolomite's product
the nadia and so this may look like a
panini press but it's actually a single
cell instrument that does
drop seek and so at first we had
the dolomite folks make us some
libraries
and we took a look at these and so uh
when we did that
we could see uh well sorry let me back
up and say that
we wanted to see okay we know these
things make
full length transcripts probably because
of the template switch all ago
technique but are these actually looking
like full-length transcripts
so in the effort to sort of walk before
we run
we wanted to do a relatively easy
experiment
and then look at what those reads look
like and so we then took the long reads
and classified them against reference
annotations and so
i'll just cover that quickly using the
scanty tool
that was developed by anna canessa's lab
this lets you take
long read isoseq data and compare it
against a reference annotation
and so a reference uh can then be
uh compared to all of the long reads and
you might find full splice match meaning
we see the reference perfectly the full
length
uh including all the splice junctions
incomplete splice match
meaning it matches partially uh or
novel in catalog means that we've seen
these exons before but we've never seen
this particular splicing event or novel
not in catalog
means we haven't seen one of these exons
so we have
a new junction that we've never seen
before
so we had uh the dolomite folks ran what
is
colloquially called a barnyard mixing
experiment
uh and that's to map match mouse and
human cells together
in the microfluidics and then carry out
pac bio
and they performed illumina sequencing
as well
and so you can see on the top here with
two different samples
we saw that many of the human
transcripts
were a full splice match and we also saw
that of the mouse
ones so it's really nice that mouse and
human have pretty deep annotations
and then we saw incomplete splice match
and these novels that showed up
at the lower levels and this is very
similar to what we see
when we take a high quality rna sample
and perform bulkies so seek
so we were quite encouraged by these
results but of course we didn't want to
do something
with those cell lines we we wanted to do
something a little more interesting
so actually took advantage of um a long
time collaboration i've had
going on with evan eichler's group and
alex paulin
at ucsf uh and that's to study
the great apes and what differences they
harbor
to make that make humans different than
the great apes
and so because it's difficult to work
with
real ape samples we have
they've been using a cerebral organoid
model so this is where you take ips
cells and push
them towards neural fates in a dish and
then we could dissociate these
uh and go ahead and assay these to do a
single cell
isoseq and short reads with them and
this was a follow-on to sort of
uh so uh the ape genome work by
cronenberg at all
and then alex paulin's work uh to study
to establish cerebral organoids as a
model for
uh a brain development
so we carried out uh the isosceque on
dissociated
uh cerebral organoids that are about a
month old and
we then uh sequenced these libraries on
the pac bio sql ii
at the time this was the v1 chemistry
and so the week 2 chemistry would
increase all of these
stats by quite a bit
and once we did that we took those reads
and and ran them through
our our a few filters to sort of clean
up some of the things that we know can
happen
in these types of libraries and sconti
can do these types of things
so one is to look for genomic poly a
priming
so we know if anyone's familiar with
single cell they know that sometimes
short stretches of a's can make the rt
take off at that point rather than the
legitimate poly a tail
so we take out those types of events and
then there's some known rt switching
effects
and then also we take out things that
don't that have
unannotated non-canonical junctions and
so
as shown on the bottom we sort of know
what the signals look like at the bottom
uh uh are at the ends of the introns in
uh messenger rnas so we look for
the gu or ag or the au and ac splice
sites
uh to filter those things out and so
then
what we got out of this is we can look
at not just the number of genes you see
in these samples and so
that was around 14 000 but we could
actually look now at unique isoforms
so we got about four times the number of
isoforms
from these cerebral organoids than you
would have gotten from just counting the
genes
so remember that the three prime end
type of product
that the dolomite nadia usually runs
using that the drop seek workflow
runs a shearing step that would just
record that three prime information but
now
with the full length information we can
actually record
isoform level information
so one of the aspects that we wanted to
take a look at
is the number of genes detected per cell
and so
that as quite a bit more genes are
detected
per cell in short read data but with
long read data we can still get a pretty
good number by not
increasing the cells to too many so if
you look at just the top
100 cell barcodes we see about 729
genes detected per cell if we look at
the top 400 we see about 315.
now remember that there's about four
times as many uh
of these isoforms so it's sort of a
different
counting that than we would do for
normal single cell biology
so one of the things we wanted to get
out of these cerebral organoids is
is this also generating something that
looks like a real transcript
so we went through some of the same
steps we did
with the the experiments i described
with the
barnyard but taking a look at reference
annotations because
gen code version 29 is quite good for
human annotations
and so again we compared what a
reference annotation looked like
to the transcripts we got out of the
cerebral organoids
and we could see a really nice size
distribution of the full splice match
and incomplete splice match transcripts
being the highest level
and these stretch all the way out to the
five or six kb
mark and so some of these are not uh
capturing some of the very longest genes
we option often capture with
the bulkheistique method but we still
felt really encouraged
by the the level of of uh profiling that
we could do
but are these transcripts real and so we
wanted to dig into this more
and so for one we wanted to look at what
is the poly a
signal what does the poly a look like
and so one of the things
we could do is look for the motif in the
mrna that looks like the poly a
signal and so there's a poly a signal
upstream of the actual poly a tail that
directs cleavage and polyadenylation and
so we looked at
what's the most common six nucleotides
that are in
that region just upstream of the poly a
tail
we saw about 60 percent of them were the
aau aaa
and second was au aaa about 16
and remarkably we look back at the
literature uh
which is pre-next generation sequencing
from 2000
and the top uh hexamers were these exact
ones
at 58 and 15 so we felt quite encouraged
that we're calling
what looks to be real polyadenylation
then we travel the other end of the
transcript and we said
can we take advantage of known five
prime end data and so this is a type of
data called
cage and so we looked at the human full
splice match
and we could often see that the the uh
there's a cage peak that's within 50
base pairs of where we
see our transcription start site in the
long reads
so this shows that reverse transcriptase
is getting all the way to the other end
of the transcript
during the single cell protocol with the
drop seek and that was very exciting
i thought it was really cool that even
in the novel nodding catalog
so these are transcripts that we haven't
seen before
with new exons or new junctions even
those
tend to have a caged peak that are uh
within 50 base pairs
of 67 of those so that's exciting
because these this could be new biology
that's in these cerebral organoids
that now at single cell level you can
start to
dissect but what about the middle
so what we did is take short reads to do
splice junction validation
and so 87 of our splice junctions could
be validated using
gen code version 29 and that makes some
sense since many of these rnas are
abundant
but 13 being novels seem kind of high
so what we did is said you know what
version 29 probably hasn't
done cerebral organoids so we took
advantage of some short read data sets
from the human developing cortex
and we could find 3.8 percent more of
those junctions
and then we took advantage of a gigantic
data set
of 21 000
seq data sets called intropolis and this
could account for another six percent
of these junctions and so we still see
about 2.8 percent of these are novel
and these could still be real because
remember we're asking for the canonical
uh
dinucleotides at the end of the introns
to be there
but i wanted you to see a sort of a look
at
the part that i enjoy the most which is
visualizing it and starting to look at
what do isoforms look like at the single
cell level
and so this is showing a gene that one
might think is kind of boring which is
eif4h and elongation factor gene
so this is a case where we found
something that
really kind of blew my mind you can see
at the bottom
uh as the gen code version 29 and
there's
a little bit of five prime in stutter of
of different
transcription start sites of the first
one versus the second
and there's an alternative exon that's
down there in the in the second to last
intron
but when we classified these these and
uh took a look more closely if i zoom in
just on that three prime end
so the three prime utr exon you can see
something really strange
and that's that there's actually introns
being removed
from the the three prime uh
utr of this this you know what i would
consider a housekeeping gene
so we can see this in many different uh
tissues
so or sorry cell types that were in here
astrocytes fibroblasts neurons etc
but what it means is that there's a
splicing event that's sometimes taking
place
in the three prime utr and the funny
thing is that three prime utrs
when they do have an intron it often
triggers nonsense decay
and so could this be a gene regulatory
mechanism to sort of
tone down the amount of this transcript
but
that's a of course a question that could
be asked now
using this type of data and then
looking at cell type specificity we
found that if we only looked at the
astrocytes so
that the cells that were classified as
astrocytes by our parallel short reed
efforts and clustering we could see that
the
tropoelastone gene is only expressed in
the astrocyte cells
and so it's known if you dig in the
literature that astrocytes
can make triple elastin if they're under
stress and the guess is
that cells in the dish probably are
under some stress
and so you can see from the bottom that
gen code annotates a huge diversity
of alternative splicing at this locus
and that includes five prime n
differences
uh alternative cassette exons internally
and also
three prime utr differences different
lengths different poly a sites
and so with the single cell information
we could track exactly which isoform
is in which uh cell and then
basically say this is the the isoforms
that are being made
and instead of boiling them all together
and just saying tropo-lassen's on in
astrocytes now this says
no it's not just on it's making
different isoforms in these cell types
so since we don't had done chimp
and human organoids we wanted to dig in
there and see if we could find anything
interesting in that
as far as something that would
distinguish
chimps and humans and this was a really
interesting that
one that came up and that's the zinc
fact
zinc finger gene znf-331
and so when we looked in this data we
could see that there's
a number of transcripts up above in the
chimp cells
that are being transcribed from the same
spots
as the gen code human transcripts if you
look down below
so these are very common transcripts
but when you look in the human data set
which is the purple
we can see that there's a new five prime
exon that's appearing
in human that's not seen in any of the
chimp data
so these are also annotated in gen code
but
these might have been predicted by a
simple lift over that
these would also be transcribed from
this exon in chimpanzee
but it appears that instead the human is
the place that that
happens and interestingly znf-331
is one of the genes that by single cell
experiments
in organoids and in primary cells
is a gene that's up in human so it's
higher expressed in human
and so those studies were done using
short reads and so they would have all
just boiled these
these reads in all together and say znf
331 is up
but by having this information they it
appears that perhaps it's a new promoter
that's driving this the transcription of
znf 331 and maybe that's why it's up
um so finally i i want to
sort of go over some of the a really
recent collaboration
we've been doing with vijay ramani's lab
at ucsf
and that's to evaluate another platform
for performing single-cell rna-seq and
so
again this is one that's been
traditionally associated with
the short reads but we thought since
this has
a similar mechanism of the templates
which i'll go we could try and see
could this also be adapted to long reads
and so celsi works in a little different
way
where there's small micro wells where
the cells are loaded into
and then on top of that beads that
encode the
oligo dt and the barcode umi
information are loaded in there and the
instrument
uh the celsi genesis then makes these
these reactions happen and
i'll i'll mention that also hot off the
presses is that celsi is now a
a affiliated biorab so
with vj's lab we took some
another approach with the some mouse
neurons
and i'm just giving you a quick preview
of these so again with
the mouse neuron libraries we see really
nice
full-length properties and so these
would do even better than our organoid
libraries did
as far as getting a long full splice
match
uh an incomplete splice match in the
scanty categories
when compared with the mouse annotations
and we can actually see even better
stretching of the
the longest transcripts above 5kb
in some of these experiments and so
do these look like real full-length uh
rnas
so we again took a look at the ends of
these
uh these transcripts that we're calling
both the tss that we're calling in the
long reads
and the poly a site and we could see the
full splice match
uh 72 of these full splice matches are
within 50 base pairs of a long read
start
and also with the novel and catalog and
novel not in catalog
reads we're seeing pretty good uh
correlation of these
so reverse transcriptase appears to be
doing a good job
getting to the five prime end of these
transcripts and
these are with mouse uh primary neurons
it's quite exciting
and then we look at the other end and
say what is there what's the distance
between the poly a tail in the laundry
data and where we see those motifs that
i spoke of earlier
and you can see that uh but quite nicely
that the peak is right around
the minus 15 mark which is known to be
where things are
uh with the terms of poly uh sorry
cleavage and polyadenylation
and so we're quite encouraged by these
types of libraries and what
what kind of biology that vj's lab can
do
so today i've told you a little bit
about what we're calling single cell iso
c
so basically taking the cell information
instead of turning that all the way up
try and turn up the information uh that
we get
out of these reads and and it looks like
about four times the isoforms can be
found
in single cell experiments than in just
looking at genes
and so this is with three different
single cell platforms i talked about
today
any of these platforms that can generate
a full-length cdna
and contain the barcoding information
can be applied to pac bio
so these are traditionally where they
have the information during reverse
transcription and a template switch all
ago
and so these can be done and you can
also divide the library and do some
reading on short reads and
some on long reads and we can determine
the barcodes quite accurately
directly out of our instrument without
cheating off of the aluminum barcodes
and i'll say that it seems like we're
just starting to scratch the surface of
the cool experiments that
that you can do with this kind of idea
one we i've talked about uh the
experiments from hogan tiltner's lab
with mouse neurons
and the experiments from ian mccauley's
lab with uh
hematopoiesis and these have already
uncovered really exciting new biology
and i think
there's a whole lot of more new biology
that awaits
when when applying this kind of
technique
so i just wanted to put up a couple
resources that you can
go to uh the pack by website and get
started with your project
we've created a single cell isis seek
library
sort of guidelines and this goes into
our normal template prep
kit pac-bio doesn't we're pretty
agnostic to which platform
makes the single cell cdna
and we just want you to get the best
data you can so
we say take that cdna and and go into
our library prep and so there's
information on our website for how to do
this
if you don't have a pac bio instrument
you can do these
experiments and amplify your dna and
then send it off to one of our certified
service providers and these are all over
the world and i've put a picture here of
our our certified
service provider website you can search
for where you are in the world
and uh find somebody that can sequence
your sample
and that's uh you can also reach out to
support
pacb.com which can give you uh an
eye into uh some of the the technical
details you might need
or put us and put you in touch with
people that can help out such as me
um and finally i i i need to
give the biggest shout out to my uh sort
of
longtime friend and collaborator liz
sang at pac bio
who has been the engine behind the ios
iso seek informatics
and the tools i talked about today were
sconti
which is an adaptation from anakinesis
lab that can do these transcript
classifications versus annotations
it's been really helpful to go ahead and
do some of the qc on these libraries
but it also gives you a lot of other
functionalities that i'd encourage you
to
explore and then liz has generated a
tool called cdna cupcake she likes to
name her
her tools after foods which i can get
behind
when i'm in quarantine here um and those
though that's the the um the package
that we use to do the single cell
information like finding the barcodes
and umis it can also do things like
generating uh
saturation curves collapsing down
redundant transcripts
and so you can go to liz's website
github.com
magdal and link into those
and finally i'll just acknowledge a lot
of people that were involved with this
work besides
liz at pac bio and brandon uh galvan and
ting han have also
participated uh in the single cell
efforts
i've been really grateful to work
closely with evan eichler's lab
over the years uh and also alex paulin
and vijay ramani's labs and so uh
last i'll thank the the partners at the
actual technology companies dolomite bio
who was so kind to run some experiments
with us both
at their headquarters and also right at
ucsf and then recently with uh celsie
uh it's been really a joy to work with
these folks
so please reach out if you if you have
questions
and uh it's been a pleasure to talk to
you today
i'm sorry that 30 kilobases of rna
is keeping us all from talking to each
other in person
but it's uh it's different times
and i encourage you to still get out
there and do your biology